Scott Eastwood is living it up in Miami  during his break from filming fast H get  out there and be the best damn version  of yourself the 30 year old actor went  shirtless by the sea at Soho beach house  in Florida and the handsome hunks  bronzed body is everything we've dreamed  of  meanwhile the Suicide Squad star has  recently sparked romance rumors with  supermodel Adriana Lima an eyewitness  told et the duo was flirting and being  really affectionate at a New York City  restaurant on Wednesday while leamas  Reb's denied that the actor was even at  the eatery a source close to Scott  confirmed to ET that he did dine at the  restaurant but claims dating rumors  between him and the Victoria's Secret  model are not true